amazon
twitter war uh which kai it kind of has
to do with both you put them on separate
pages i'm gonna try to do this with page
two and page four
so on one end amazon right now uh union
vote is bigger than amazon okay
why the amazon union vote is bigger than
amazon the verge article says
for last seven weeks workers at the
amazon warehouse in bessemer alabama
have been voting by mail on whether to
unionize if the union wins the warehouse
employees
would become the first members of
amazon's u.s workforce to uni unionize
a momentous event at a company that has
long aggressively resisted labor
organizing and that
one that could be the first step toward
improving conditions at the country's
second largest employer employees say
amazon's demanding and automatically
enforce productivity metrics average
rate at the workers
perform a task okay productivity metrics
makes work grueling stressful and
dehumanizing
amazon tracks two metrics the average
rate at which workers perform a task
called tact time and how much
time they spend not scanning items
called time
off tasks if workers fail to maintain a
fast pace they get reprimanded or fired
amazon's the second largest employer
with 800 000 employees
6 000 warehouse employees tom
thoughts you know isn't that interesting
we're talking about the military going
softer on their recruits and here in
amazon a great point you know
it's it's everywhere in this country
it's unbelievable this is a
this is the probably the one and only
thing that keeps jeff bezos up at night
because
is this going to be a domino effect if
one of them unionizes and it's the last
thing that they could possibly want
now the people that are pushing pro
union
and man this thing's if you really
follow this just the
the marketing the advertising on both
sides because
there's a lot of these employees that
don't want to unionize
they're going to have to pay dues right
and some of the things that amazon
offers that you would think
a union would eventually get for you 15
to start
and automatic benefits right as soon as
you start so if it's such a horrible
place to work
why do they employ so many people how
come more people aren't quitting or just
not going for the job
um the the vote's not we're not going to
know until the very end of the week and
the other thing that they keep trying to
push
is some of these weird stories about how
employees can't take a bathroom break
and they have to pee in a water bottle i
don't believe that i think that's a
bunch of bs
i don't think that is happening it may
have happened one time
and they take it and run with it you
know i worked for ups
for one summer when i was in high school
that was one
tough job and it was in the union that
was unionized at the time
i wasn't in the union but i could just
sense that whole
union attitude right and some of my tv
jobs the stations was unionized so it's
a totally different world this is so
anti-bezos anti-amazon i think it will
be a complete disaster
if the union vote passes you know when i
was at the tv station like
you couldn't edit a story at a certain
time if the editor was on break
you know all these mandated break times
they had to take or a smoke break
or you couldn't do this you couldn't you
couldn't put something on the set
because someone on the union had to
actually put that piece of paper
or hand you a pen so i personally i
don't think it's gonna pass
i think amazon is too powerful there's
no way they're going to allow this this
is just going to be a huge pandora's box
that would open
if it did pass so it's something to
really keep an eye on and i think we
might know
by the end of the week how this thing
goes so let me give you a different
perspective on our uh
amazon here we go um i actually went
down a rabbit hole of research to figure
out like why do people join unions what
are the pros what are the cons what's
going on who's back in the union who's
not bad
back in the unions and if i'm looking at
this and i'm an ali freaking bama
and i'm thinking should i be a part of a
union should i not be a part of the
union what are the pros one of the cons
all right cool
so what are the cons all right there's
costs there's dues that we talked about
you got to have
you got to put in time and you got to be
a part of this union you gotta be part
of activities
all right cool what are the pros well
first and foremost
if you're a member of a union you make
uh
non-met not non uh members of a union
make 82 percent of what a union members
make
okay 82 when it comes to retirement and
planning for retirement
if you're a part of a labor union 93
have retirement benefits
versus 64 versus non-union okay so the
math is like all right
looking like a union would be good let's
not forget it was about 100 years ago
when the
um fort went forward and and the
industrial revolution was coming to
america and everything
working conditions were ridiculous you
were working 15 hour days they had no
let's not compare the two the average
work the average hours we worked in that
time was 69 hours a week
okay so that's the uh we're at 37 38
hours a week right now
all right really it's not even 40. we're
working less than 40 hours a week okay
and we're
you cannot even compare the two together
but i get what you're doing good it was
a disaster i agree i don't disagree with
that guy is figuring out a way how to do
a four-hour work week every single day
he's reading that book
but uh when it comes to to sick leave
maternity leave
hourly wages benefits retirement
packages pensions
there's a lot of pros being a part of a
union i think that they're going to
actually come to their senses
in out of freaking bama and vote to
become a part of the union and here's
the biggest thing
jeff bezos is the richest man in the
world okay okay
amazon has a what million and a trillion
and a half
market cap it's not true two trillion
dollars approaching
sure these workers are making
amazon the wealthiest company
potentially in the history of the
universe certainly jeff bezos
the workers are the workers are oh it's
not it's not the the vision of the
of course it is and but thank you
thank you for setting me up there's
enough money to go around
that who dictates the workers who can
get their fair share
bernie sosnick over here okay sorry so
are you so that's bernie sanders
argument right
so i'm not saying that's bernie sanders
i'm standing facts here okay you're
saying you're just saying
well no problem how about this how about
the fact that bernie sanders
pays where's bernie sanders at what
state is he at
new hampshire vermont what's vermont's
minimum wage
11.75 and it's on its way up no
no no i don't think you heard what i
just said vermont is at 11.75
and amazon's at 15 bucks who the hell
are you to tell others what to do when
you ain't doing it to your own state
the hourly wage is like the moment but
no no what i'm trying to say to you all
the unfair [ __ ] that's being thrown
around
is being thrown around by a guy that
doesn't even pay his people
what the minimum wage is imposing on
others this is the biggest hypocrite in
america today
you want him to pay 15 bucks he's doing
it you're doing 1175
at vermont who the hell are you i'm
sorry where's the scrutiny with you
answer that damn question
what does bernie have to do because this
is all started by bernie all of this is
bernie
all of the union is burning everything
about this is bernie i don't know let me
i don't know why you're so heated i'm
feeling the burn right now
no i'm i'm not heated at you i'm heating
that bernie i'm not heated at you
what i'm trying to tell you is the
following so i just wanted to say let me
let me give
let me give the feeling about this with
bezos this is bezos's problem
let's identify bezos bezos votes
democrat with the government but
republican with the way he runs this
company
make up your damn minds who you are okay
are you a democrat
or republican or is it just you vote the
way that goes into your pocket and
regulation
here's the other part you got to be
thinking about do you know who is the
vice president of global affairs
for amazon do you know who it is that dj
jazzy jeff no no jazzy do you actually
know who it is no no no no do you know
who this is 2015.
do you know a guy named jane carney
who's jay carney
who's carne who's jay carney can you
pull up who jay carney is you're about
to flip out pull up who jay carney is
okay you're about to flip out who jay
carney is the moment i pull it up look
at the reaction with the face
who is jay carney put up he was the
former uh he is the
former press secretary to barack obama
but he has now been the vp
click on his wikipedia click on his
wikipedia everybody knows who this guy
is look at the last sentence at the top
go all the way to the top where you were
at
last sentence carney has been senior
vice president of global currency on
amazon since march 2015 overseas public
policy and public relations on amazon
business around the world and reports a
ceo and founder jeff bezos
this guy reported obama now he reports
the jeff bezos regulation so let me get
the straight bezos
what are we doing here images so the
challenge for the people that don't know
who this guy is this guy was on tv
every single day you know that face
under obama
so biden bezos goes and hires them so
this is not
just a level of accountability to one
side and not the other side
if you think about what bezos is doing
as you start
making more money the problem becomes
the following
here's the problem i'm uh
i'm leading these different uh groups
the ceos are asking me to do these
groups because they want some kind of an
advisory board so i'll sit down and i'll
go through in the small groups we do our
elite monthly webinar they're 90 minutes
with me
it's only seven i do one one that's a
bigger one but i do these others that is
only seven of them and i sit on the
board great
and we process issues together we just
kind of go through and we process issues
together
what do you do with this what do you do
with that what direction do we go with
this how about this how about that
one of the guys i was talking to he had
bad relationship with his employees
and he kept having bad relation with his
employees and i said let me ask you a
question why do you have such a bad
relationship with your employees
yourself why do you keep having these
problems i said how often do you even
go and talk to them and ask them about
their dreams
how often do you go speak to your people
on your team how often do they see you
oh no that's not what i do that's
somebody else's job i said okay
you ever read the book lincoln on
leadership no i gave the incitement of
him reading lincoln on leadership you
know what's one of the rules on lincoln
on leadership
circulate amongst your troops
something both bezos and biden would
benefit with
biden and kamala here still haven't gone
to the border for what
i have no idea why they haven't gone to
the border you're giving your opinion on
what should happen without you going and
taking the lead because you don't want
to go out there why are you not going to
see it
trump would have been out there in a
heartbeat clinton would have been out
there in a heartbeat these guys would
have been out there in a heartbeat how
come you're not up bush one tonight
in a heartbeat how come you're not out
there how come you're not going looking
at this
bezos how come you're not going out
there and finding out the pain that
they're going through
realize this as you become bigger a lot
of times the challenge and i've seen
this with folks who you go from
you know 50 000 to six figures you know
the six figure guy cannot have the same
kind of relationship
then you go to a quarter million and a
half million million all this other sub
there's like let me tell you who i am so
you can't have the regular conversations
right one of the biggest things when my
friends call me from 20 years ago
they say dude you still joke i'm like
dude i'm just
richer it's the only difference i'm
still the same
guy i've just read two thousand more
books my mind is a little bit more
different i'm not as naive as i was as
an 18 year old kid but i still like
jokes i still like a good prank
bezos has to realize pay your guys
fairly
okay go give the benefit program if
they're asking for retirement
give it to them set some criterias say
we don't do it if you've been here for
90 days or six months
create a criteria fyi if union gets
involved with amazon you know who takes
the biggest pain
customers that's who does yeah the
stuff's not showing up
yeah so so it's like okay sorry we'll
get to the next day like dude why
you ever talk to some company employees
like the other them on the phone with
this bank uh
uh it's a big bank i wish i could say
the name i don't know what the bank u.s
bank
and this one lady i'm like ma'am i'm
asking you basic questions why can't you
ask me to answer this question you know
what sir i really don't have time for
this jen's sitting right next to me
hang up she hung up on you i called back
i'm like did you guys record who i spoke
to last no we don't have that
so how is that person held accountable
the accountability goes away
and people can get away without giving
the right customer service then that
spreads
i just talked about it right now it's
customer i do it as a company
that i have to get these hey this person
said this about you well maybe we ought
to get better at customer service
maybe we ought to figure out a way to
get better at this stuff maybe we ought
to pay a little bit more attention maybe
we ought to make that additional phone
call they say you don't have time to
call until monday
call the person hear them out why are
they upset at you what did you do maybe
we did something wrong
this whole thing about wrote a letter to
a 3200 word letter to my
one of the people you and i were talking
about it you know what i said i said
as a school gets bigger i hope you guys
are not an elitist organization where
it's an
honor for others to work for your
company versus it is an honor to have
people
who are willing to say yes to work with
your company i understand what it is for
me to have a resume where i say i worked
at netflix
i worked at amazon there's a certain
prestige to it
but guess what people have 50 other
places they can work out as well and
they chose to work with you so
there's a balance here that's going on
that bezos has to sit there and realize
brother just give benefits with
criterias and and
good kudos to them forgiven 15 minimum
with something
our legendary socialist guy who loves
russia and vermont hasn't been able to
do and he's been there for how many
years 40 years you can't even raise the
minimum wage from 1175 to 15 bucks
and you're bashing everybody else good
for bezos
pesos goes a little bit more take all
this stuff out but he ain't playing
around he's got the right people in his
corner to want to fight against all
these things that people are doing right
especially guy like jay carney why would
bezos be so anti-union
why wouldn't he concede a little bit
maybe not i didn't say
everything i said was do it without
union union will
union will change the culture of amazon
it will be
felt yeah you know here's the other
problem that that's happening right now
is there's going to be such a feeling of
division inside those
um fulfillment centers and throughout
the whole company i can only imagine
you know it's an us versus them
mentality in there and then you got
pro-union workers it's almost like
republican democrat
it's probably this a cancer that's
starting amongst the rank and file of
amazon that's going to be a huge huge
problem for him and you know i
i do i mean there's no way you could
identify what bezos really believes
he owns the washington post right you'd
think the washington post would be front
and center
trying to get this this place unionized
and having huge stories about that all
the time
and that's true too everybody that's
saying that they should unionize
this and that are the same people that
want those packages delivered the very
next day
right so you can't have it both ways and
i'm not
convinced that union officials truly
have the best
interest in mind of those factory
workers or or people that
you'll drive the forklift or the or the
drivers here's the other thing too
compare you constantly see amazon vans
out there right
i mean this is such a phenomenal that
wasn't there two three years ago right
the amazon vans are everywhere how else
would the packages arrive
these guys to me now this is just my
observation they never seem stressed
they they're they have a sense of
urgency but i'm not seeing these guys
looking like they're all frazzled
or anything like that and and maybe
there's some amazon drivers that are
watching this and can tell me something
else
sometimes i see fedex guys and they seem
a little bit more
nervous you know not under control or
same thing with ups
i'm not seeing this from these amazon
employees and if it's so horrible why
don't they quit
something's keeping him there probably
that's that starting wage of 15 bucks
and the benefits the benefits is the big
hook for amazon and they make that
available for everybody on their very
first day bezos is going to win this he
wins everything there's no way that
place
is going to unionize you don't think
that that place is going to
i don't think so i don't think they'll
be successful uh
i don't know about that i don't know if
i agree with you
there because the last decade
has been a streak of a lot of great
ideas not winning the last decade has
been a streak of a lot of bad ideas
winning the last decade has been a
streak of a lot of uh
uh anybody that cries me a river has
been winning
uh a lot of people that should have
performed and had a job
lost there's no a guy comes out with a
shoe
that's got a blood in it confirmed with
nbc that there is
the employee's blood in the shoe little
nas x this shoe that he comes out and
called luke 10 18 out of the bible
scripture that he uses
that shoe doesn't get canceled right but
a guy
who gives his opinion on merkel gets
cancelled
appears morgan gets cancelled kevin hart
gets cancelled all these other people
just because they have an opinion
they get cancelled and all these other
bad ideas unfortunately are not getting
canceled people have to wake up and
realize
that this canceled culture is canceling
the wrong things
and if i'm a betting man if i'm a
betting man who do you think
wins you think bezos carney and the
trillion dollar two trillion dollar
company wins or do you think aoc
uh bernie sanders uh elam omar oh you
think you think those guys
who do you think elizabeth warren who do
you think's gonna end up winning in a
situation like you know bernie went to
alabama and sat down
one of the things you got to plot bernie
here's one thing that bernie does that
bite
the thing that i respect more about
bernie
take bernie's philosophies out take
bernie's all of his philosophies out
take all of my philosophies out
i have more respect for bernie's dog
fight than biden's dog fight
because you know what you're getting
from him bernie is a fighter
how old is burn how old is bernie today
can you actually pull up bernie's age
versus biden i'm actually curious to
know
how old is bernie sanders going with 17
are you saying that he he went to
alabama
he went to alabama he may have just won
out to his porch to get the newspaper
and got lost and ended up in alabama
point is a 79 year old man went to
alabama but a 78 year old president
cannot go to the border to see what's
happening over there yeah
so so you got to get respected but you
also cannot undermine the fact that
these guys got power today yeah
bezos cannot sit there saying oh they're
going to win this no matter what because
these bases i don't think that's the
case two things
let's look at some point we don't have
to do it now i wonder what bernie's net
worth is that guy sells a lot of books
he's not poor okay he's probably a
millionaire
hey he better be a freaking millionaire
79 years old okay and last
night fifty grandfathers here's the
prediction and here's why i think
i would i would have i would have more
respect with him if he if he's a
multi-millionaire versus
if he was still poor okay okay like
you're 79 years old save your damn money
i'm talking about i have no respect for
him at all hey five thousand he loves
5000 employees in alabama right what's
stopping amazon to going to
2600 of them and paying them money to
vote no on the union
i they've been working on this thing for
months but could you still do it
no you could do it but if you do that
then the media wins because they're
going to say look exactly what they did
it would be a big old uh uh publicity
stunt they would get destroyed
covertly covertly imply amazon can
officially not do anything covertly
amazon can no longer do nothing covertly
period
you are you got the lenses like this and
all
eyes on amazon scrutiny yesterday
at the highest level so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye